hey guys this is pete peppers with candy
crush sodasoccertips.com
and this is a level 223
candy car soda commentary walkthrough
with tips
um this is a frustrating level if you
played it you already know that there's
a bunch of cakes and blockers
and it's really hard to get them all out
of the way so you can
get the two bears out at the bottom
so in the beginning there's not much
choices you just want to hit the cakes
you just want to like try to make
stripes like i did here
and fire them down
don't want to get too overly fancy
combos will be great but
we need a little bit more space first so
you know here we'll just fire off the
orange stripe and make another orange
stripe at the same time
and here we can set off the other orange
stripe by this and clear out a little
bit above the fish
there are two big pink fish um
there's one at the top here and then
there's another one in the middle
and we don't really have to try to get
the one at the top
because it'll it'll sort of work itself
out anyways
and then you know as you can see just
making stripes and firing them off
and wrapped in stripe combos are great
too so we're going to try to
see if we can get a couple of those
and you know there's only a few colors
on the board so a lot of the times when
you set things up they're going to get
fired off anyway so
don't don't worry about that just just
keep it going and hopefully what's going
to happen here
is now we have a little bit of space
we can set up some better combos and
we're going to look for either you know
coloring candy and color bomb combos
or like a coloring candy cascade kind of
situation where we can set one off
that'll
create another one since there's only a
few colors you know you can get sort of
a um
a chain reaction going with those
sometimes
so when we get here we gotta only have
14 moves left we don't have that much
damage yet
but we're getting to the point as you
can see that things are really going to
start to
to cascade if we think it out um
you know fish plus wraps really aren't
that great
on this type of board so you know i
don't rush to make those
just looking like i said to try to
cascade the pieces down when i can
alright so here we're going to get a
coloring candy it's going to go off
right away but
let's see if we can't get some other
specials out of the deal
that's um that's pretty good
yeah this sort of that chain reaction i
was talking about that can happen
sometimes with those
it's just it's just it just enhances the
cascade and
as you can see we got a full third
excuse me a full third further onto the
board there
so now we just wanna we only have nine
moves and a lot of blockers but we could
we should have like a great
chance to get um combos at this point
so we just don't want to do anything too
quickly just try to find
the best spots and um that would have
been nice if you could see there i was
trying to
match the stripes with the um
color bomb but even though we didn't get
it we still got a really great cascade
and the pink fish at the top came out
so now i'm gonna um
i'm going to try to work out this middle
pink fish
but i'm also going to keep an eye out at
the top for chances to make coloring
candies or color bombs
and you know they're obviously dropping
the wrap down
is better for me than um making the one
at the top i mean i got the double at
the top anyways but
it was too far away from the blockers at
the time to really worry about it so
when you have a chance you know think
about matches that are at the bottom
and we all know that if you you know if
you messed up at the bottom
stuff can cascade down and that's that's
always good
so we're not out of the woods
necessarily but
i think once we make this striped plus
color bomb we should be pretty close and
with two moves left hopefully we can
clear it out
yeah we're gonna just have one one piece
of ice there so
um we can make another fish and match
them together and finish
it off there's only one square of ice so
it's going to clear it for us
and there we go so you know when this
level first came out you know
i was just like you i had a really hard
time
getting things to set up for me but um
you know i made this to show the tips on
how to think your way through it and you
know it's going to take a lot of try
sometimes
but the main thing is just to really
take your time and think about what
you're doing
it's kind of that thing where you know
you can get you can just start exploding
things and making specials everywhere
but you have to be a little bit you have
to plan it out you know so i hope this
helped
please like the video please subscribe
to our channel so you can
keep up to date with all the new ones we
put out and i'll be making new videos
like this soon thanks